[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to a charity stream
from min max and
gamespot i'm ben hanson from mid max i'm
joined today
for a little video game trivia by
blessing junior from kind of funny
yo what's up thank you for being here
blessing uh jake bellino from game ranks
hello what's up not much brandon jones
from easy allies
trivia serial vasquez from midmax hello
siri hello
so even though this is like game trivia
and technically you're with mid max and
i'm with mid max and i'm hosting this
thing i promise
i do not send story all the answers
ahead of time this is all going to be
completely above
i didn't even think about that yeah i
swear i swear uh alessandra from
gamespot thank you for being here sir
oh thanks for having me yeah absolutely
uh so this
is not only video game trivia game case
trivia specifically
but this is also a charity drive and so
thanks to gamespot for reaching out to
us it's very generous for them to
offer an invite to say hey do you want
to help raise some money for what was an
amazing pivot on their part so now you
can choose from the links at the bottom
of the screen if you want to donate to
black lives matter
or to cover 19 direct relief go any
which way you'd like
i think those numbers are going to be
updated over there and if you donate
alessandro will be able to see it
i think he has a neural implant so he
will download all
donations and let us know and be sure to
thank us in between video game rounds
because that's
what we're going for here um let's see
alessandra just because you're from
gamespot do you want to talk a little
bit about the charities that were chosen
here
uh sure just uh really quickly uh first
up we have
a via act blue uh game spot stands with
black lives matter
um this is obviously just for to help
out you know
current activists and you know
protesters and also to help you know in
any way possible to stem
the tide of just police brutality and
just you know general hatred
uh this gun in this country and beyond
as well
um so we also have the uh you know
direct relief uh this is for kovid
uh relief directly um this is uh gonna
be uh basically just helping out you
know the people on the front lines you
know people in the hospitals like you
know people
trying their best to help people you
know during this time you know uh
because unfortunately we're facing two
epidemics right now one is
called the 19 the other is against
racism and
general bigotry of all kinds so um
unfortunately it's a perfect storm of
just all that
just happening at once but honestly this
is the best time to just
try and try our best to really just try
to change things for the better you know
for everyone
and especially people of color so yeah
those are our two
uh donation uh sort of uh charity drives
right now so
um feel free to uh you know give what
you can for either one so
yeah for sure i mean it is that feeling
of i mean especially if you're watching
the stream you're probably
checking twitter every once in a while
and it's so overwhelming it's so
numbing just to read all this and just
feel like voices aren't be heard what
can i do what can i do
uh here's one thing you can do on either
topic whoever you'd like to donate to
uh we'd appreciate it and gay spot would
appreciate it so you know
we'd always appreciate if you reached
out and took a little bit of an action
here today
in between some fun video game trivia so
this is
game case trivia we used to play it uh
back on the game informer show that's
you know i was at gaming former for nine
years cereal you were there for
years as well yeah great perfect and
then we played a lot of
uh this trivia game uh and then brought
it over to
mid max when we started mid max uh late
last year which is a patreon about games
friends getting better
and so the way it works is i have on my
phone i took a picture of a bunch
of game cases the back of video game
boxes
i'm going to read the descriptions from
the back of the boxes omitting
key words like names obvious giveaways
it's always that delicate
fine line about what is a giveaway or
not
everybody here you can buzz in by saying
your name
so you buzzing everybody gets one guess
and the first to five points
wins the entire thing and the prize
is going to be uh you can plug anything
you want
on the midmax show podcast throughout
the month you can plug your own
you can plug charity i'm not going to
tell you what to watch whatever you want
you can put words in my mouth you can
call me a jerk whatever you want we'll
go for it
uh hey jake i i've never met you
but uh how are things going over there
hi i think
things are okay you know we're uh doing
the best we can
uh here in new york things are starting
to slowly
open back up but of course we're
tackling multiple things at once
uh we're trying it's also nice to meet
you in person big fan
of the stuff you guys have been making
forever so i'm really excited i'm also a
really good
i'm really really big fan of this
concept too so i'm ready to
ready to play i'm ready to lose okay i'm
ready to play awesome yeah it's funny
when your name was thrown out i was like
okay jake belden i don't think i know
him i'm sorry for not being very
familiar there's like
oh before you buy oh god i was like oh
wait i just listened to you on jeff
grossman
you don't know game ranks yeah no i
obviously it was a huge blind spot but i
listened to your interview
uh on uh you know jeff grubb's podcast
as well is that you seem like a very
smart guy yeah absolutely jeff has a
podcast
i'm learning so much about everybody
today this is great last thing it's nice
to be on here with you um
let's see i'm trying to remember we dm'd
a while ago because we were committed to
playing darwin
project together yes that's what it was
i was like man i knew i'd like had some
sort of connection with you yeah we
wanted to play darwin project
uh sadly i don't know if you saw the
news but they're they're stopping
development
on the game apparently what the game
wasn't doing as well apparently
apparently us two were the only two
people that were playing darwin project
right which is tragic
because that game is great it's a cool
game yeah you play and be like this is
pretty cool i hope this catches on oh
yeah i guess not and like it's still
servers are still up so we could still
play it's free to play outside service
are still up until the end of the year
as far as i understand
and so i'm still i'm still down for
darwin project
like it's a great great for for
everybody who doesn't know because
probably most people probably don't know
it's like a battle royale that's like
limited to i want to say like 10 people
you have somebody who's playing as like
the master like that's uh organizing
what's going on
it's like small arena you're doing like
a lot of survival kind of stuff it's
very much
it's more hunger games than any other of
the battle royales
it's really great it's really fun it's
really ridiculous also now alessandra we
will keep talking about darwin
project from 2020 until one donation
comes in so if you see anything coming
in
please let us know
what a great give me your candidate
honestly
we did get some donations oh great you
want
yeah just go ahead and thank those folks
would be great yeah sure uh first up uh
for uh
game squats that ends with black lives
matter we have uh 25 dollars from
paris aerosmith uh thank you for that um
and also bob buell who donated 50 as
well
thank you so much bob that's awesome uh
brandon jones how's everything going
over there
good it's such a what a pure thing
meeting somebody else in the industry
over a cancelled game you know it's like
you're going to be it's going to be
three years from now you're gonna bump
into each other at some award show or
something and be
having a drink you're both gonna be like
yeah darwin that's right yeah darren
remember the day what was that january
yeah it's still
recovered i think back to 2020 i'm going
to think of darwin project no doubt
about
it uh oh of course brandon jones hosting
uh the easy ally's podcast now how's
that experience going for you
it's going great i goofed up the last
time i mentioned you because we also
have a ben we got ben moore on our team
and i said something about ben working
someplace else and like you know gave
like 200 people a heart attack they were
just like ben left what's going i'm like
no
okay all right i got it last names
matter last names are important yeah
absolutely well hey thanks for being
here everybody um always pleasure yeah
okay so the first to five wins whoo
are you ready i'm nervous no not at all
man this is forget about that some of
these
are real real bearcats as my old math
teacher used to say they're tough
questions here
oh well thanks thanks for embarrassing
us man i really appreciate it glad to be
here all right you're all video game
experts right before i start this no
matter what you're going to nail it
allegedly yeah okay allegedly
starting with a tough one just a heads
up revival
of an ancient evil once banished
rebirth of a land once destroyed
renewal of love once lost
now i like this game i would not have
led with any of those but okay
two great he likes this game that's a
clue oh crap two great continents
one an advanced civilization driven by
progress and technology
the other where nature is the center of
all existence and everyone lives
harmoniously side by side
two cultures that have never had contact
with each other
until now an ancient evil has been
unleashed
journey on a quest through time to
unravel the mysterious tale
of the blank okay now
now we're getting specific here we go
that could be anything
okay innovative innovative new game play
g okay georama
build it oh blessing blessing uh dark
cloud
yeah blessing way to go dark cloud on
ps2
say that i recognize that i know what
that is of course georama is iconic
it's like it's an iconic system of
course uh you go into dungeons you
collect what's in the dungeons you make
your town
dark cloud underappreciated absolutely
i'm going to say that
i never played that cloud too i know it
seen as better was georama in dirk cloud
2 as well is that just the first one
i didn't play dark cloud 2 and so i
don't even know which
i know is is a travesty given how much i
love dark cloud 1.
um but you know like playstation hits or
free on psn or
playstation now cloud easily somewhere
yeah ps2 to ps4 is what it's part of it
was like part of that original wave of
games that were ps2 games that
they put on ps4 yeah dark cloud both
dark cloud and dark cloud 2
are on the psn store on ps4 if you want
to go play right now
had a chance on that one well i mean
i feel like the innovative new gameplay
was kind of a dead giveaway
now i know i know i didn't realize there
were two kingdoms
i know as i was reading and i'm like
this sounds like xenoblades like
warcraft
okay here we go enter an unseen world
in blanks blank colon
the game the official video game based
on the epic
action-adventure movie journey deep
into the heart of blank and ignite the
ultimate war
on an alien planet
ratcheting clank incorrect jake jake
uh the avatar game wow jake
dammit wow was it james cameron's avatar
though
sorry yeah i was gonna guess peter
jackson but like then you said aliens
and i was like
i don't think i remember the movie that
well but i don't think aliens are happy
to show up for pandora thank you yeah
disney plus right now go check it out
what's wrong with me so hey just to be
clear no one has chat up right i know we
love the community involved
alessandra's here but i feel like they
might be giving stuff away so no no
cheating
scout's honor here alessandra how are we
doing for donations by the way
uh we're good uh we actually got a few
right now for uh direct relief for covid
uh related uh you know
charity um first up we have jay lopez uh
gave in twenty dollars and just got
another one right now um
uh jay lopez says love you all if anyone
sees this comment reach out to a friend
or family member for me
these are hard but a solid hey i love
you can help
an honest one one for your fellow human
being
thanks that's really nice thank you
that's very sweet
uh we got 20 dollars from siku as well
with uh two uh donations from uh two
separate anonymous people uh one for
five dollars and another for fifty
dollars
awesome thank you so much everybody all
right here we go
music tames the savage beast an entirely
new type
of music entertainment play
as the legendary blank man and save the
planet
from the clutches of the evil grevillian
family
10. uh surreal eternal sonata no
oh yeah ten serial come on you're giving
me max a bad name you gotta step it up
ten colorfully unique stages each with
its own music
including reggae hop hip hop
rock slow jams techno and more
i like that they lead with reggae and
include slow jams okay uh
musical death matches and harmonizing
co-op play up to four players
the blank uh brandon brandon frequency
no no okay the blank is the weapon
keep the rhythm as you defeat enemies
using extended guitar solos
jake jake is it guitar man yeah jake
wow did you play this thing
that's amazing did you play this guitar
man had all those genres
yeah i didn't know either i've never
played it so um oh
i know i'm impressed okay here we go
build an adventure of mechanical mayhem
blank are facing their greatest
adventure yet
brandon brandon um no it's uh
oh banjo-kazooie the one of the three
it was the ups and downs or what was
that i don't even remember
all right so the verdict would be
blessing kind of gave the
point to jones
cameron's avatar what are we doing here
all right well that's a good question
how is track do we want to be with this
i'm going to err on the side of being a
little bit stricter i think but
you know it's a great i want to give it
to brandon because i wouldn't have
gotten it i wouldn't have gotten there
okay
i oh yeah you had me they're famous
because i was like oh that sounds like
nuts and bolts
uh and then you said their greatest
adventures i'm like okay this is a
sequel this is
they you know you read that description
you would have known based on them i
know those names
right right like it's gotta be all right
all right there's a lot of rumors
bubbling on the internet though that
banjo
uh banjo-kazooie ups and downs is gonna
be coming and it's gonna be
i can't wait for greedy great
all right keep your feet wet and your
powder dry
as an elite commander your team has been
called to fight terrorists in 12
the most deadly missions ever with more
than 30 weapons
superior intelligence intense training
and unparalleled skills and tactical
maneuvers at your disposal
protect freedom wherever it's in danger
headset inside utilize the blank headset
to communicate and plan strategies with
felipe
jake uh us uh socom us navy seals
there we go oh my god
kill it we just did jake video on that
so it's it was fresh in my mind the
headset the
like little pack in headset that you
have to yell at the ai
with the headset it was it was brilliant
oh wow
uh wow so we're at uh blessings at one
jake's at three jones is at
one alessandro is at zero but he's
really at infinite for the amount of
comments that he has to read
uh and then surial is that zero cereal
you're killing us
please i also have no comments to read
okay here we go grab your joystick
and get ready to unleash your inner
blank distinctive
blank humor raucous and racy
just how you like it voiced
and scripted by members of the real
blank
tv show creative team blessing blessing
south park the stick of truth incorrect
hilarious and entertaining
non-sequitur mini games keep the laughs
coming
non-sequitur minigame all right brandon
brandon family guy game
there we go keep killing it
that was really going to be our best
clue throughout the entire thing all
right okay here we go
you are blank a powerful
young blank on this
powerful a mysterious storm has swept
your family from the sea
the search to find them will take you
through vast underwater realms of
treachery
beauty and adventure use your sonar to
discover hidden caverns
and unlock the secrets of crystal glyphs
jake jake that echo the dolphin that is
echo the dolphin
point holy i thought gonna be a
metroidvania type thing because i know
there was like underwater metroidvanias
okay in my head i was like all right
what is the what is the game where
you're a human your feeling gets taken
by the sea because i want to play this
game
that's badass uh we have some
do we have some time to read some
donations that's all we're here for
uh uh for uh game squad stands with
black my lives matter we've got
quite a few come in actually um what's
up william garcia 100
uh thank you that's great and uh we have
jesper lawson
50 all the way from denmark uh thanks
for you know thanks for tuning in
uh we have uh daniel montes with fifty
dollars
i've uh uh and stay with me here uh
mondo
aka elder delgado uh the hundred
the hundred dollars
uh yo monta is fifty dollars
uh patrick polk twenty five dollars and
casas clay
uh 1.77 cents oh my guys are showing up
there we go thanks so much everybody
yeah thank you again uh the links donate
are at the bottom of the screen on
either side you're welcome to
choose whichever one you'd like um
should we up the um
the winning total to 10 by the way
because i feel like you're trying to
steal it from jake
look i mean jake seems like a lovely guy
he's very handsome yeah the rest of us
are warming up now so yeah
exactly all right bump it up to 10. we
can just do another round okay
now only one i was waiting for somebody
to get to four before i really
showed out right and really like ramped
up i come from behind victory
yeah yeah that's what i was looking
forward to but it's fine i'm down for
pretend
okay here we go one of the biggest and
best rpgs of all time
levels up with a larger story new
character
and events online dungeon rescue system
and more uh cereal surreal persona five
royal
incorrect blessing blessing
personal for gold yes for stonehenge for
goldman oh
surreal that's brutal so close
i'm sorry cereal i'm sorry i i know i
know things
i i guess i don't know was apologizing
to me i guessed wrong
hey man you just you got that kind of
face we're just sorry man
you're a good powder okay here we go
solve the puzzles or join the tormented
souls
forever within a world of enchantment
and wonder
evil resides in an ancient castle
blank a young boy born with blanks
has been a blessing
jake's at four jones is at two surreal
is it's not important and alessandro
it's also not important
okay way to go i love it it's like the
perfect description yeah solve the
puzzles
or join the tremendous souls that's
that's all that game is well as soon as
you said puzzles i was like all right
i'm in because i love puzzle games and
then when you said souls i was like
all right this is either titan skulls or
shadow colossus and then when he's when
he got to the boy born born with blank
corner horns or did you say blank yeah
bore me blank i was like i know exactly
what this is
okay here we go the final terror
exclamation point
launch into the biggest rpg ever on the
genesis
uh this is the explosive magic and
monster packed finale
to an incredible blessing golden axe
incorrect to be incredible that's the
only one i know
alessandro a shiny force incorrect
finale to the incredible blank saga
an ancient hideous dark force stalks
the eagle sorry al gold star system
oh fantasy star three incorrect
oh oh it's under got
oh saved you already made your guess
oh no only get one guess does anybody
else want to jump in
brandon brandon fantasy star
[Music]
[Laughter]
no it's that part of the rules i'm sorry
no regrets no regrets
all right i thought fantasy star was
canceling it i didn't even think about
jumping from one sequel to another i
didn't also did not know four fantasy
stars around the genesis wow yeah
yeah i would not have that either
there or anything that was all genesis
god mega drive oh wow not sure
uh more donations alessandra uh yeah one
second
that was dirty i'm sorry no hey you
gotta do it look
uh yeah we have one donation coming in
for uh direct relief uh
from uh conrad peaks uh thank you ten
dollars awesome thank you so much
all right this one goes out to that
owner here it's time to rip the galaxy
a new one jake listening
jake ratchet and clank wow jake thank
you bye
all right that's right great minds think
of like
wow no we know we know what games are
great man we know we know we know
what's out there all right
uh remarkable from ign
in big letters here so what's their most
remarkable game that they've ever seen
okay groundbreaking multiplayer
invade single-player games plus play
adversarial
and team modes team blessing blessing
this is gonna suck because i don't know
this series that well
but assassin's creed brotherhood
incorrect mobile companion app
interact with blank on the go
open world freedom to play your way
hacking i think i know what this is is
your weapon uh
what's under alessandro uh watchdogs
there we go
watchdogs got on that big board
you start to just smell that ubisoft
like you'd be soft
i like even for watch dogs one they just
have a bullet point that just says open
world
like that's a selling point like 2013
2014. like
watch dogs watchdogs was my first go-to
but then like i remember you said
remarkable and i was like
certainly that couldn't be
that hard for you that was a loaded
remarkable band you were like
remarkable yeah the e3 demo was
remarkable
okay here we go become a blank
master blank plus 100 other blank moves
play in first person for the first time
includes the exclusive debut of
episode of blank anime
50 plus playable characters
free qr codes inside
use special qr codes to unlock
characters and power ups
play the entire blank saga in story mode
i could guess the franchise but no way
i'm guessing the game yeah
become a blank play in first person for
the first time
first person man it's not a good game
at brandon brandon one piece pirate
warriors
incorrect okay let's see um
i'm looking at the bullet points we have
object scanning
one player
there are leaderboards oh blessing
blessing oh they're leaderboards um
dragon ball z budokai three incorrect
uh cereal uh i think cereal might have
that one
uh dragon ball z uh tenkaichi
ii incorrect jake i was gonna say
tenkaichi three
oh man alessandra have you gone yet
um dragon ball z xenoverse i don't know
oh no sorry i thought there would be
more tails here is dragon ball z
connect oh oh come on i should i should
have hit that become
a super saiyan thing we don't have a
thing it's tough
that's tough that's funny oh it was a
connect game where you could be
i don't know yeah oh yeah was that what
it was
oh no sorry it says uh become a super
saiyan yeah
i can't tell if that would have made me
look good or bad if i got that right it
would have been amazing
the internet would have loved you the
donations would have started pouring in
with major points
okay here we go we have some new
donations first
um like uh game swap uh stands by black
lives matter um
uh unemployed 25 thanks
thanks for donation spot's own tamor
sane
uh comes in with a hundred bucks next
man he's a
fantastic dude thanks thanks so much and
uh we have 15
from phil uh thank you awesome thanks so
much everybody
all right play the action movie
oh boy scion is a blank
in a dog street bar called fate
in order oh uh alessandra alessandro
what's up the bouncer yes
he's killing it on the board jones it's
something you're talking about
oh yeah i was playing all the wrong ps2
games apparently i needed to
no i think you're playing the right ones
actually we all made mistakes
i know the game i'm familiar with that i
just the main character's name but no
yeah the dog street bar called like the
quintessential
playstation 2 game in my view yep just i
was so hungry for
a jrpg on the ps2 so when they came out
all right well square
released the game on ps2 i guess i have
to get it and uh you know i finished it
40 minutes later and it was great
uh okay in a world of darkness and magic
power hungry warlords battle one another
for control
of feudal japan at the height of the
chaos the noble princess
blank is kidnapped now jake jake
annie musha warlords yes way to go
jake that's okay perfect
wow yeah those games need to come back
like please
they released the one on switch wasn't
it they had like that remaster right
it did not sell incredibly so yeah i'm
with you jack you know i hold on to it
but um
i'm embarrassed yeah my head was in
dynasty warrior space
oh yeah sure demon siege uh okay so
blessings at three jake's at six jones
is at three cereal is that it's not
important and alessandro is at two
all right this one is this one's tough
it's good to be the king
uh uh forever oh sorry sorry
yes mr duke nukem forever do you want to
i guess i said my name but i mean you go
ahead
go ahead i said yeah
uh okay well i had another one in mind
but not i kind of want to steal it
because he was very confident i'm going
to say duke nukem forever
oh it doesn't pay no that's not
it and now you look terrible oh
i swear to god if it's the one that i'm
thinking oh man you'll all feel my fury
okay just kidding expand your kingdom
oh sorry little king story yes
sorry a little king story on we that's
awesome way to go i was gonna say the
lion king
i was gonna say concrete wrong it's not
good to be that king that's a bad king
congress that makes sense uh all right
here we go
in the distant future a small group of
human exiles
have been doomed to fight for their
survival on the edge of the universe
three powerful species are locked
blessing
blessing beyond good and evil incorrect
are locked in a fierce battle over the
fate of the galaxy
the time for war has come cereal
jake the technome answer incorrect
surreal
starcraft incorrect alessandro
that's my guess too actually
well i guess you have a free chance if
you want to guess anything else that's i
don't really have anything alessandra if
you want to guess absolutely anything
else that might be dangerously close
uh just say starcraft 2. you got it
aircraft too why not
incorrect aircraft food war right now
features all of the original characters
and units
from starcraft and brandon
brandon uh starcraft remastered or
starcraft battle chest
no what craps are they uh
buzzed in yet blessing i think all of
this is gone
okay this is this is gonna be the
giveaway requires the n64 expansion pack
i feel like i was closest but you were
the closest i was on the fence about
giving it to you but uh a tough round
tough round
okay
grunty returns blessing
blessing i feel like that's a blank
situation but yeah go ahead
what forget whether or not i forget if
whether or not if nuts and bolts
was the correct answer earlier um but
i'm just gonna say banjo-tooie
it's banjo-tooie way to go blessing
bouncer it's like you know it or you
don't yeah yeah exactly i was hoping
maybe the tui thing would throw people
off
okay so this is um
we need the exact name of this game
okay oh boy hang on let me
let me make sure i have it it's cutting
it off
on my screen any donations in the
meanwhile alessandra
uh yeah uh come one come in for uh
direct relief
uh this was a hundred dollars from
anonymous
thank you so much you know for
uh game spot standards by uh black lives
matter uh we have
uh uh tom blackburn uh donating uh
25 bucks thank you thank you so much tom
uh
jimmy with uh ten bucks as well
anika berry uh ten dollars as well
awesome thank you so much everybody
again links are at the bottom of the
screen jump in whenever you want
okay exact name only
cheetah only the cool
can rule blessing blessing
oh wait i shouldn't have gone um
cool spot that's that's it that's my
answer
correct it feels right a twist
yeah yeah for sure all right uh
put yourself in his paws you're a cool
cat
so you would like to be treated like
that but no you're stuck in a zoo with
nothing to do
mean eugene the zoo keeping fiend has
planned an ugly scene
he wants to nail your tail without fail
so he steals your wheels to cool your
heels
i think this is muhammad ali he wrote
this actually um then he hides the parts
in the zoo just to fool you
and that's just the beginning of in
eugene's way of winning
but stay cool and you can rule just find
your bike and you can go where you like
the rule is cool remember
a cool cat is just
blank
so it's a it's like a racing it is on
the sega genesis
get a life this mean eugene the zoo
keeping fiend just won't give up
hey dude get a load of this when chester
loses his cool he geeks out
what a cat let
special graphics and effects don't get
much cooler than this
yeah baby he's showing us the box art
and we're still not able to
we're just morally refusing to guess
this game yeah baby this is an adventure
you just don't want to miss
um let's see all right
it's the chester cheetah game on genesis
which it was a deep cut it is officially
called chester cheetah
too cool to fool you cool the
okay here we go join blank on an
incredible action
rpg experience blank has been summoned
to stop an evil force
to save the kingdom and rescue the
princess
embark on a wild comical action rpg
adventure
in a massive 3d world filled with
platform-style action
two-fisted sword fighting challenging
puzzles
i'll take it back wait did you guess
no i i almost i said half my name and
then i thought about it at night okay
i hear weird breaths okay uh and scores
of enemies whose skills
blank can learn and use to his advantage
locate five powerful magical scrolls to
conquer the twisted
thirst quencher empire
a blessing blessing brave fence to
musashi
wow blessing yes the ultimate thirst
question
that's amazing earthquake quencher
because in my in my mind
at first i was like zelda ocarina of
time but then i was like that's not
he's not he's not he's not too he
doesn't uh hold his sword two hands
right he's left-handed traditionally i
think
um and so i couldn't it couldn't be that
my mind then went to
final fantasy seven as he went on
because he mentioned being like a 3d
game and all these different things it
sounded like a square game
but you said you said wacky and also
like there's no princess in that game
that's the thirst quencher there's
quencher was the word
because as you know if you love
breakfast musashi it's a game that is
all that's that's very food themed
right like there's a lot of food things
right and there you go
i remember my favorite thing about that
game is when you die musashi would say
if i get reincarnated i want to be
musashi again
oh yeah he did say that it was nice uh
alessandra any donations
uh yeah we have quite a few actually um
uh gamespot uh stands
with uh black lives matter uh we have a
kiss uh with a
25 thank you
rebecca with uh 10 bucks
uh jeremy uh jeremy long with fifty
dollars
uh tim o'keefe with another fifty
dollars
uh prometheus with uh twenty five
dollars way to go king thank you helix
yeah and felix uh denata de notress
with uh fifteen dollars uh moving over
to uh direct relief
we have uh jesper lawson who uh
previously also donated for
our pre our other donations uh
charity as well uh with uh 20 dollars
and we have king prometheus again with
25 and this time with a message saying
love this game have fun everyone that's
very sweet thanks so much everybody
awesome
again uh links at the bottom of the
screen to donate and we'll read your
name out loud on the stream here
all right meet blank
he's a feisty little flame spouting
blank
on a gigantic go anywhere 3d
fantasy adventure cereal cereal spyro
the dragon way to go
cereal the dragon the first one
which in a stream earlier today somebody
was saying i don't remember this at all
but
there's like first person sections in
spyro three
does anybody remember this i guess like
you're the dragon just like this weird
doom clone sex you're
the dragon that's what somebody was
saying uh maybe they're wrong
okay i don't recall but it could be the
case i mean there's so much crap packed
into that third game i mean it's
probably easy to forget skateboarding
exactly uh okay flying in that game as
well
the actual like actual flying like well
the first one even had like those flying
levels whereas like the time you go
through all those gates all that
nonsense okay here we go
the fastest first person shooter ever
created for a gaming console
the blanks are an evil race dwelling
outside of
time and space roused from an ancient
sleep
they crossed the threshold from their
from their shadowy dimension
ripping through the fabric of blank
to make humanity history jake jake
time shift incorrect
can we unite against a common enemy or
will we be condemned forever to
a realm ruled under the shadow of the
blanks
experience furious multiplayer action
for one to four players
arm yourself with the deadliest weapons
of the past present
and future blessing blessing
time splitters there we go first time
splitters way to go
blessing okay blessings at six jake's at
six
jones at three serious two alessandro at
two first to ten gets a plug
all month long on the midmax show
podcast okay
oh no do we lose jones no no is he
outraged this screen is frozen yeah
it looks like yeah my back uh not the
video i hear you
but oh hey hit the load for a second
there we go perfect
there we go getting in their head jones
smart really suck them out here
what if i disconnected and came back so
how many did i miss one because i think
i know
yeah we'll just give you a point here uh
because yeah okay here we go
the world famous hmm
um okay the world famous blue hedgehog
is back fully
rendered graphics with 256 color
textures
thrust sonic into an exciting 3d playing
environment
blessings sonic adventure incorrect
damn it the evil genius robotnik is
after the chaos emeralds and it's up to
sonic to stop him
rescue the innocent flickies before
robotnik turns them into part of his
evil plan
sonic 3d being black
there we go sonic 3d blast way to go man
good job uh i remember they made i've
played way too many games on my game
gear and i remember like the weird
version of that was just called sonic
blast where there's
remove the 3d but you get the idea okay
oof this is another really tough one
here
it's time for greatness brother
get pumped hulkamaniacs
bring the pain in this action-packed
no-holds-barred
wrestling experience that lets you throw
down hard hits in your living room ring
learn the ropes is it
hulk hogan's the main event wow
like that wwe legends game but i think
as you lead more into
the act the the whole bit i think i i
realized it was
it's a connect game isn't it it is yeah
unfortunately wow
i was going to guess like nes i remember
that uh
dan reichert at gameformer gave it a two
out of ten i believe it looked
completely miserable
that that was my first hint is that like
that's that game damn it oh is that
right oh wow okay
blank your way
you hold in your hands the ultimate
power of creation and destruction
design build and rule your own thrilling
blank with real blanks as the main
attractions
command blessing blessing rollercoaster
tycoon
incorrect jake jake rpg maker
incorrect command everything from the
ticket prices
to the blank the world brandon
theme park correct the world
of blank is yours
alessandro uh
jurassic park evolution incorrect
uh oh well now i'm gonna feel bad if i
miss this uh
surreal uh is it you're in the movies
incorrect
that's everybody right uh it was
jurassic park operation
genesis you were so close yeah
oh man i'm so excited you remember the
name of it yeah
okay from the creator and developer of
the 20 million
selling blank series comes the next
generation in interactive entertainment
enter a new world of magic and adventure
exploration and discovery where enormous
vistas and exotic characters lead you to
places beyond your imagination
test your wits and your skills as you
embark on a journey to reverse your best
friend's transformation
into a furry blank jake
jack and baxter way to go jack and
daxter oh wow
jake said that's seven wow yeah i love
daxter
okay franchise i guess crash bandicoot
yeah
already blank pals around in an
all-new action adventure
don't listen to that description it's
not correct um blank's back
in his in his first adventure since
blank and this time blank's bent on
preventing a storybook ending
when blank is kidnapped
blank plots
to there's a typo on this box which is
unbelievable
plots to rescue the seven blanks
uh brandon brandon shrek two
[Laughter]
i'm sorry it's trick three no uh uh and
rid the blank
of blanks cruel cohorts blessing
paper mario the thousand-year door
incorrect
as he travels from the tropical jungles
of lava lava island
to the frosty heights of shiver mountain
he'll meet up with seven all new
companions
and he'll need help from each one or
there'll be no happily ever after
popular after so strange master the
ability of blank seven new sidekicks to
save the seven blanks
and topple the king of evil himself
ready your reflexes for a blank action
adventure
the active turn-based battle system
makes fighting
blanks baddies equal parts strategy and
timing
mix and match badges like
quake hammer is it surreal is it paper
mario sticker star incorrect
uh jump charge and lucky day to blank
to make blank more powerful than ever
over 50 badges in all
discover over 100 items to aid you on
your adventure
mix them together to cook up even more
fantastic creations that'll help you
close the book
on blank
any guesses
five four three
two jake jake metal gear solid three
subsistence
just hoping to get a plug-in forgot
about the badges
incorrect it is the first paper mario
blessing you are so
close as you kept going i was like oh no
i messed up i messed up that's so tough
okay
madness and mayhem in this 3d
gorilla thriller blessing blessing
donkey kong 64. incorrect what
blank is back with a new sidekick blank
in a crazy island adventure
challenged by the crazed tribe of
reptilian blanks
they endeavor to get back their stolen
blank horde
okay alessandra
uh uh donkey kong country two uh diddy
diddy's conquest incorrect but i like
that you got the name right
uh cereal cereal donkey kong country yes
duncan
country one way to go wait they
described it as 3d
they call it a 3d gorilla wow
it's very misleading here then yeah
and then the sequel was the gorilla
furlough in manila that's right yeah
yeah yeah uh uh how are the donations
coming alessandra
yes uh we got a quite a few actually um
just uh for uh direct relief we have 20
bucks from
mitchell because great people and great
game
this is a ton of fun to watch thanks all
thank you
and for uh for black lives matter we
have uh
joe long joe lawlin with a hundred bucks
michael morin from with uh 25 dollars
and he has we have uh osvaldo manzo with
uh 25.
thanks guys awesome thanks so much
everybody
all right minimalist design here but i
think it's cool
the crystal comes back
finally this is a quote from egm
egm says without question blank is the
best looking game in the series
in every way blank takes the best of the
old and mixes it with the best of the
new brandon brandon
final fantasy 13. incorrect right
that's all we got folks
oh really the crystal comes back without
question blank is the best looking game
in the series in every way
blank takes the best of the old and
mixes it with the best of the new
uh jake seriously all that those are
good final fantasy crystal chronicles
incorrect
here's a hint the character they have on
the back of the box that's huge
is by far the most forgettable character
from this game
five four three three
cereal fantasy ten incorrect
i think twelve four
three two also
um uh
i was gonna say it too but be fair
though i was thinking about it
when you said like the most forgettable
i was like oh wow okay okay
you know what yeah why not is it omron
the guy with red hair he's just huge on
the back of that game
oh yeah yeah yeah that's right yeah
okay now to call shenanigans was that
was that alessandro's first guess
because i recall somebody saying crystal
chronicles that was me
oh that was you all right wait you
failed me out for a second
oh my god i apologize i just want to
make sure i just want to make sure
things are fair
i'm very worried on how i'm doing right
now if anybody wants to yell shenanigans
at any point we will hear you out here
okay here we go i apologize directive
colon eliminate the blank
virus intelligence has confirmed the
development of biowarfare weapons
blank your only chance to destroy the
blank virus
you've been cleared to use lethal force
to complete your directives
and that's all a quote not from a gaming
magazine but from
markinson so markinson from the game is
saying that
uh then operative profile
classified oh my god education
a master's degree biochemistry
rockefeller institute
a bachelor of science degree yes
the division incorrect guerrilla warfare
expert
counter-terrorism special reconnaissance
sandro alessandro
a win back wow win back reference
nope that's a great guess oh my god
direct assault and stealth
expert combat weaponry specialist
silence nine millimeter handgun night
vision rifle grenade launcher and more
navigational expert 13 real world
open 360 degree environments jake
jake siphon filter wow jake
yes that's amazing that's good nice dude
that was hard
that was super hard uh so blessings at
sick jake's
at eight jones is at three cereals at
five alessandra is at three
first of ten wins let the hunt
begin you are blank
the most fearless blank in the galaxy
hired to capture a deranged dark blank
armed with an array of deadly weapons
and skills you'll face off against
galactic scum from the darkest corners
of the blank universe
jake jake odd world stranger's wrath
incorrect
brandon brandon star wars bounty hunter
yeah
killing it brandon wow well the
universe the blank universe was too much
that's okay that's
that's on the brain i guess i almost
immediately thought of star wars but
i was like i don't i had maybe played
like four star wars games so
i do
i assume the blank was bounty hunter but
my mind went to metroid oh
sure of course yeah okay
this means war the battle lines have
been drawn
and an elite group of sly strategists is
massing troops at your borders
you'll have to command ground air and
naval forces
if you hope to survive the coming wars
and it won't be easy
with 114 maps to battle on and both
single pack and multi-pack link mods
advanced there we go stereo with
advanced wars
that is your favorite game of all time
or near it surreal
it's uh the the ds one is like my third
favorite oh
nice wow uh yeah cereal right cereal
once told us that he thinks about
advanced wars every single day of his
life which is amazing
and this was today's
all right meet the new crazy
60 levels of platforming madness
immerse yourself in full high def glory
slap your friends in four person
multiplayer
take on epic bosses and uncover hidden
secrets
that's all we got
slap your slap your friends in four
person multiplayer is the best hint you
got here
meet the new crazy 60 plus levels of
platforming madness
uh brandon powerstone incorrect
60 plus levels of platforming madness
immerse yourself in full high def
jake jake uh fusion frenzy incorrect
five four blessings blessing
uh rayman origins way to go blessing
yes really wow oh my god absolutely
that's incredible
for some reason i thought it was a
connect because of the slap your friends
think cause it's like oh you can play
and then like the platforming thing
threw me off so
you're super mario brothers maybe yeah
okay
this is no pickup game it's a twisted
adventure created by
vengeful mad scientist dr
max cranium he has kidnapped an entire
basketball team
and they're under lock and key in every
corner of his dark and dangerous lair
beneath the streets of blank
control blanks every move as he takes on
the evil dr max cranium to rescue his
teammates
alessandra alessandro uh pull jordan in
the windy city
do we give it to him ladies and
gentlemen it's chaos in the windy city i
think that's so
good way to go man
it's not like it's chaos when you in the
uh 64 right that's a total
that's completely different completely
different i appreciate it thank you
on the back of the box of this they have
power up with special wheaties and
gatorade health boosts
that's awesome uh this is uh the
wheaties
blockbuster so that was nice that's my
only one and only memory of the game
it's really i hope they release a bonus
episode of the last dance that's just
about
chaos on the windy city i want to know
yeah i mean they made one about space
jam basically there's one in there so
they may as well that's true all right
uh thousands of years into the future
man exists only in deep space
brutally opposed by a merciless alien
race
humanity faces an uncertain destiny as
it unlocks the secrets
of the universe in search of the
ultimate truth
an epic adventure delivering over 80
hours of gameplay
stunning graphics breathtaking
cinematics and beautifully rendered 3d
environments
music performed by the london
philharmonic orchestra
four exhilarating minigames innovative
battle
and control systems
minigames and the philharmonic what's
going on here
80 hours of gameplay it's these are
weird hints but they're technically
only four mini games in 80 hours of
gameplay huh yeah like let's go
how do you have only four mini games
when you have 80 hours of gameplay and
symphony each minigame is good for 20
hours it's a very weird game
thousands of years into the future man
only exists in deep space
let's see brutally opposed by merciless
sailing race humanity faces uncertain
destiny as it unlocks the secrets of the
universe in search of the ultimate truth
hmm very existential game
five four three
two blessing blessing explore
incorrect zenith
all right what were you going to guess
advent rising oh interesting yeah xenon
how obscure can i get in terms of like
far out sci-fi the debate with this is
if somebody guessed in a socket would we
make them say the german was it like
their wilder mocked or whatever at the
end
all right how are you doing on donations
alessandra
yeah we got a couple just come in uh one
for uh direct relief uh raykus once
again uh
20 bucks uh love and respect he says
and uh for uh game squad stands with
black lives matter we have walter van
halderen with uh 20 dollars all the way
from uh canada now thank you
you so much for the donations guys yeah
awesome yeah again
also i should mention that uh we
actually crossed seven thousand
uh during this uh particular uh you know
go so uh yeah great job guys awesome so
much everyone for donating as well
yeah for sure that's good let's get on
the screen we will read your name
out loud uh okay this photo's blurry but
i'm gonna do my best
welcome to the mad house
descend into the core of the criminally
insane
as the blank launches his most
diabolical plot
ever the inmates
blessing psychonauts incorrect
jake jake uh batman arkham asylum way to
go
jake hell yeah wow okay
blessing is at seven jake is at game
point nine
jones is at four serials at six
alessandra
four that one hurt jake that was that
was rough that's rough
all right your eyes on the ball man i
appreciate it when
when one man is not enough
never fight alone master two-man
blessing army of two yes blessing
oh man we got a horse race here oh my
god go get it yeah
all right blessing's at eight jake's at
nine my caden lynch
okay select one of
seven ferocious
blanks then pound your opponents into
submission
as you battle for earth domination
oh god
blizzard uh brandon yes brandon oh
primal rage
way to go brandon yeah bible rage
wow on the tip of my tongue and
apparently that's earth with a u
uh and it's capitalized earth domination
i don't know if that's a theme in the
game or what the hell that is
it's a copyright thing uh a dinosaur
fighting game right
yeah yep yep yep okay here we go
all right a quote a quote from game
informer magazine
they say it's like fresh powder on a
sunny day
it doesn't get any better than this
unbelievable next generation graphics
and awesome control deliver the ultimate
blank experience five daring downhill
courses
carve and shred in 3d texture mapped
alpine tracks that require the highest
levels of skill and intensity jake ssx
incorrect brandon brandon 1080
snowboarding incorrect
[Music]
choose from 10 hardcore blanks each
blank has its own unique attributes and
design
awesome characters with their own unique
attitude and style
innovative ghost data allows you to race
against the replay of your best run
surreal surreal uh tony hawk's downhill
jam incorrect
eight rip and cd soundtracks and two
dynamic
playing perspectives that intensify the
experience
catch air and pull off maneuvers like
360s
1440s flips back and front sign board
grabs
ollies spins and fakies
if i had to give a hint i would repeat
shred in 3d texture mapped alpine tracks
unbelievable next generation graphics
five and blessing
did you buzz in uh no i didn't buzz in
okay
four three two
blessing blessing uh i don't know man
tony hawk pro skater
incorrect this is tough alessandra
oh
[Laughter]
it's such a tough slice and time to look
okay next gen so it's the start of the
generation
they really care about the cd aspect
yeah okay
1080 was my it was the one i was
thinking of until brandon said i was
like i have no idea i was thinking of
amped i was like it's got to be amped
bam it's in your blood
just days after surviving the grizzly
disaster
at the blank lab blank resigns from
blank
and attempts to escape a nightmarish
city in ruins
alessandro incorrect
trapped in a town crawling with hordes
of blanks
hideous mutants and a relentless
new blank uh oh uh
blessing uh half-life two incorrect
she must rely on cunning brandon brandon
resident evil three way to go
technically nemesis but i think we gotta
give it to you way to go man
all right jones you're at six blessings
at eight jake at nine surreal at six
alessandro at
four okay any any new donations
alessandro
uh yeah one sec sure that made up for
our comments we got it we got a
first off for uh direct relief we have
10 bucks
from matthew theis uh dan gave hulk
hogan's main event a one
not a two oh wow thank you for fact
checking out
that's what compelled them to donate
yeah
they gotta know um whatever it takes uh
but what uh for um
uh game squad stands with the black
lives matter we have 55 bucks from
um edgar cereal cereal's new haircut
vasquez
all right very sweet um
then we have we have a scott hildendorf
with 25 awesome thanks so much everybody
again links at the bottom of the screen
we'll read your name and message on the
show
all right the majestic
master of sneak invites you
to go behind the mask
the game is
sneaking the objective is
sandra alessandro sneaking where way to
go
wow i was thinking it's like a that was
a pretty big tell there
just saying the name of the game yeah
that was a subtle hint
i should have known i was going to say
cooper i was like i don't think he ever
wears a mask
yeah yeah yeah does he or is i guess
it's a natural mask he is the man
yeah that's tricky oh boy okay
think evil breed evil
control all get in the action and become
the blank
the uh overlord wow
yes overlord are you a fan
no i just i just remember a lot i
remember wanting to buy overlord 2 and i
remember it being like a game where you
managed minions and stuff oh wow
uh all right that one's too tricky
okay classic japanese side scrolling
action
action transformed
created by games industry legend blank
and a veteran team of developers
blank takes the best elements from 8 and
16-bit classics
ninja gaiden incorrect brandon brandon
beautiful joe incorrect jake
jake shinobi incorrect
eight and 16-bit classics that you know
and love and transforms them with modern
tech and fresh mechanics into something
new and amazing
run jump and blast and transform your
way through 12 stages using weapons and
abilities
stolen from your enemies play
online co-op missions or go head-to-head
blessing
uh this is the mega man x
incorrect damn or go head to head in the
online
race battle mode dozens of challenge
missions
optional 8-bit music three unlockable
extra difficulty modes and more
includes the ray expansion pack
new vermilion destroyer stage boss
battle versus rey play as rey
in her quest for answers plus art book
and double-sided poster
classic thing is on me now really this
is mine to lose
created by games industry legend blank
classic japanese side scrolling action
transformed
they really want you to care about those
transformations and ray
ray is huge we
five four oh yeah three
two got nothing sorry that's fine
mighty number nine ladies and gentlemen
mighty number nine
god i guess you transformed there uh
okay explains why i didn't know the name
rey
yeah i was like wait that must have been
that kickstarter game then yeah yeah
exactly
uh which remember they announced that
was it red ash like their mega man
legend successor like
we're gonna find it anyway and then
nobody has heard about it since
uh all right all right that one's too
generic that's impossible
okay get
get blanked in this haunting new
adventure
battle blank blank and a host of
terrifying new ghosts
in an all-new adventure written by the
creators
of brandon brandon ghostbusters the
video game way to go
jones yeah shout out to that game this
is
this is getting intense this is blessing
at eight jake at nine
jones at seven circle at seven
alessandra at five jake hi dude over
there sweating
yeah i'm actually sweating it's the
lights
but i'm sweating for real out of
nervousness
okay blank has pushed the technology
envelope to the limit
this platform game is unlike anything
you've
seen or played before 65
000 eye-popping colors 60 frames per
second
and up to four independently scrolling
backdrops
all of which pull you into the screen
and right into blank's outrageous worlds
over 50 different characters that will
freak you out crack you
up and give you a challenge of a
lifetime amazing powers
which develop and accumulate as you
progress through the game's 70 levels
to help you ward off enemies and avoid
some of the strangest encounters
six mind-boggling bizarre worlds
complete with different climates and
jam-packed with hidden passages and
traps leading to unexpected combats and
rewards
all this in cd quality sound with over
200 different sound effects
welcome to the next generation
cd quality sound
platform game is unlike anything you've
seen or played before
amazing powers which develop and
accumulate as you progress
five brandon brandon
gexx
you sound like you just went for the
counter in the 90s and somebody asked
you what game you want you're like
i didn't
i would have taken that with me to the
end of
the end of the road five four blessing
blessing
uh sonic cd incorrect
three jake jake blasto
wow no not blasto
there are not that many colors in blasto
you know you know that's a 60 000 color
limit
three two
one
rayman the first rayman everybody very
tricky very tough
okay everyone
is here
smash brothers yeah way to go blessings
oh wow
all right game point blessing and jake
are both at nine oh my god
i'm so nervous
oh i'm scared to read this one okay
game fan says blank will be one of the
best
playstation games of the year
go big blank style
blank as legendary blank
or as one of nine top pros
work your way jake tony hawks pro skater
there we go
jake
railcraft shirt congratulations jake
well done one on tony hawk
thank you tony congratulations you win
the honor promoting anything you want on
the midnight show podcast throughout the
entire month
so i don't know you're welcome to think
about it if you know off the top of your
head what you'd like to promote we'll
also take that
it's going to be a charity ah if you're
cool with that i think i don't know
which one very smart move all right
send me send me some text and and we'll
read it on every episode thanks so much
thank you for that opportunity
yeah thanks so much for playing
everybody uh how are we doing on
donations alessandro
yeah we just got a few more in uh for
with uh get game spot stands with
black lives matter we have charles
charles mcgregor with the 10 bucks
thanks charles we have a true
uh yep we have a christian uh jagi with
another 10
as well nice awesome thanks so much
everybody uh how's everybody scheduled
you want to keep going through some
other ones for some bonus rounds just
wait for your donations
let's see let's make it um no pressure
right right no pressure
zero pressure i mean just pride that's
all we have yeah yeah
okay strap it on
surial
answered very quick all right take back
what's yours
reprise your role as the supernatural
assassin
oh syria surreal is the honor too way to
go sorry
wow these are the ones your worst energy
before whoa
those are like two very specific ones
that i remember
clearly the stress is gone you know yeah
yeah
exactly can't choke anymore oh wait a
minute
hang on a second okay yes life and death
at the end of the universe blank
transports you to the farthest reaches
of the solar system
playing as the reluctant hero leo
stenbuck alessandro
alessandro oh [ __ ] i just forgot
right now i'm sorry um
[Music]
oh man this is the worst oh no one
oh sorry alessandro uh
you'll command a giant mechanized
robot into high-speed
aerial combat against a heavily armed
rogue military regime i just remember
and this really hurts right now
but massive weaponry isn't the only
thing in your hands
the fate of your entire space colony
depends on your actions
and you're about to discover that
decisions of life and death carry more
consequences
than you've ever dreamed brandon sounds
awesome
brandon it is zone zone of the enders
way to go yes
awesome i love that game too but the
idea of the name
leo stenbuck sticking with me for 20
years is impossible
yeah i'll never forget it now all right
uh any more donations you're welcome to
jump in at any point between these
alessandro
yep sweet uh nothing right now but yeah
great uh again we'll give you a shout
out if you donate to the links the
bottom of the screen for either of those
life is blank
official playstation magazine says this
could easily be considered the best
superhero game ever
meet the world's newest celluloid
superhero
introducing blank an average guy that
gets caught up in a crazy stunt-filled
action movie world to rescue his girl
oh cereal surreal way to go beautiful
joe
you got it there it is wow
blank and the blanks team up for an epic
adventure
explore four iconic worlds solo and
local co-op
play discover a modern
combat adventure built exclusively for
the nintendo switch
system
blank and blanks blank
uh mario rabbids kingdom battle yes way
to go blessing
i love like they go out of the way to
avoid saying tactics or strategy
and it's weird that like with paper
mario they also don't mention rpg
anywhere they just call it
an adventure game you know i'm sure in
this modern era ben a lot of people have
released these uh
you know have written these with this
game in mind you know knowing that
oh that's true one day they might get in
there and that's true
sneak past everybody i did talk to
somebody uh who like used to listen to a
lot
of us play this game uh back at game
informer and they're like yeah i then
had to write the back of a game box
it was impossible it was completely up
in my head about the experience because
i don't want to sound cliche and be like
that's right
blank's back ladies and gentlemen
especially the crystal
all right a hero must rise from the
ashes
take the reigns of a battle-ready blank
and defend the assylians against legions
of
mokai soldiers as rhone
you will change the destiny of a dying
world
engage in visceral aerial and ground
combat
presented in high definition 1080p in
true surround sound
tilt and snap jake that's andrew
there jake yeah jake's got it it is
layer way to go
the six axis wireless controller to
steer your dragon
uh awesome let's see oh
man an electrifying adventure
with blank a first blank adventure
for everyone swing the joy-con
to catch blank
blank together share your adventure with
a second player
oh it's cereal sorry sniper clips let us
oh uh
what no i don't i i don't know what the
subtitle is oh uh
so you haven't heard the subtitle cut it
out together but that's not it
uh yeah connect for more fun this game
connects to
blank and blank plus
accessory an electrifying adventure
with blank electrifying swing the
joy-con
to blank
blank together this is so tough okay
connect for more fun this game connects
to
blank go and blank
accessories blessing blessing
pokemon let's go could you be more
specific any of them uh
pokemon let's go pikachu yes way to go
with that electrifying
anything in there we needed it sweet
nice actually let's go eevee
we just cannot give it to you okay
welcome to town
it's time to move to blank
the real life game that's happening
every second of every brandon
animal crossing yeah you kind of no all
right jones
every time you buzz in you go oh or um
like your first word is always an um
[Music]
any more donations
yes so we have uh 25 bucks for uh
from uh juan cabrera for uh game spot
stands with black lives matter
thank you very much awesome we
appreciate it juan
uh jones how have you um so you did
like are you still doing the easy allies
podcast this week or is it just going to
be the the charity stream and then
you're cutting it off there
still doing the podcast yeah okay uh it
was just yeah tuesday was just kind of
the
the juggle of like do we take tuesday
off do we do something we kind of did a
little bit of both
right right but yeah it's tough are you
having a tough time figuring out
how to talk about these issues you want
to just i know it's a tricky time
yeah no i mean it's that's the thing
about what we're going through right now
specifically with
um you know all of the black lives
matter and all of the race issues of the
last week
is it's directly affecting the video
game industry you know like
you know events are getting delayed you
know announcements are being postponed
you know it's really interesting seeing
what companies have come out and said
messages and so
i think that's you know definitely a
conversation we can have even if it's
usually a business focused conversation
it's like well this is where it's it's
in everybody's business now there's just
no way to avoid it so
yeah thankfully yeah and i mean the mid
max community is very sweet
um but uh i think they've all been
really accepting i don't know
normally there's that mantra of like
don't talk about politics but it seems
like this is an issue
that's kind of surpassed that old
complaint about like well
can you even call it politics anymore
it's just basic humanity at this point
that's why we are all here yeah yeah uh
blessing it seems like you've been
talking about things quite extensively
on kind of funny games daily
yeah yeah today was today especially was
one of those days where three out of
four the news stories had to do with
like either company statements or things
being delayed like
fortnight uh their next season is being
delayed uh because of the protests going
on
uh infinity war they came out and talked
about how they're gonna institute some
some more moderation as far as like user
names and racist content is concerned
uh and uh to to the point that brandon
just made right like it's in all of our
business
right like it's in uh it's in the news
right it's a thing that's affecting
affecting all industries and that people
have to pay attention to and it's been
really
uh cool talking about it with other
members of kind of funny and the guests
that we've had on and with kind of funny
community
uh because like for me as a black person
uh
as a black member of kind of funny you
know it's a thing
like police brutality and the way that
that black people are treated
um a lot of the time is a thing that
affects me directly and it's a part of
my life and it's a thing that i can't
really avoid talking about because it is
it is so
intrinsic to how i've been brought up
and how i've navigated the world
uh and so it's been very i was gonna say
very fun i don't think fun is the word
but it's been it's been very satisfying
actually getting to
to talk about this stuff on the shows uh
and have black guests on kind of funny
games daily and have those voices heard
uh and have people hear from uh
different voices that they may look up
to or they might
may not be aware where about uh the
homie khalif adams of spot on me was a
kind of funny game's daily he was able
to
uh to give very good perspective along
with xavier woods of the wwe
yeah uh and paris of gamer tag radio
um so we've in in the gay patello of
married to the games like we've had so
many voices come through
and be able to really speak to what it
is like
being a black person in america um which
you know for people who might not be
aware right like there are that
like the experience is different like
there's no like if ands butts are about
it right like
you know we're all we're all different
people you know my experience is still
different from
alessandro's experience it's still
different from any other person of color
experience or white person's experience
but
there is some commonality there as far
as like
you know what it's like when you're
approaching police or when you're being
approached by police and how you
how you should behave or um uh
just like the everyday life thing of
like walking down the sidewalk in the
evening and
and feeling like you should cross the
street so that people don't feel
feel threatened if you're walking in the
same direction as say like a white
couple or white family or something like
that
uh so we're having like we've been
having a lot of real conversations that
i think have been getting through uh and
have been
opening up ears and minds to differ
different perspectives
uh and it's one of those conversations
it's one of those things where i hope
the conversation doesn't end right i
hope it's i hope
we can continue to to go on weeks months
years from now
and continue to listen to each other and
continue to learn from each other and
and you know
not just and it's not just like a black
person thing too right like
when we're talking about different
groups of people whether it is
uh like this month is pride right
whether it whether it is people
uh that are from the lgbt lgbtq
community
or people that are that are uh you know
different people of colo
color or people from uh from whatever
culture it may be right for whatever
whatever group it may be
i hope people continue from this hearing
each other listening to each other
uh taking in what people have to say and
learning like that's the biggest thing
is hearing and learning and so that's
the thing that we've been doing a lot
this week uh and it's the thing i hope
uh that is if it's a thing i hope has
been working
uh for people when i think it is yeah i
don't know how much you've been reading
the comments but if you noticed
eyes opening have you had any moments of
just reading the comments and seeing
somebody be like okay i think this
person's
starting to get it instead of just being
ah politics no thanks
i i purposely stayed away from from
reading comments and like reading reddit
and reading
uh any sort of like forum kind of thing
uh just because i'm trying to like stay
focused and not get distracted and not
get like
discouraged you know if i see something
that that i don't vibe with
um but to to that point i have been on
twitter quite a bit because twitter is
kind of hard uh to ignore
and you know i've the reception has been
amazing like the reception has been
incredible
i know over the weekend specifically
like the kind of funny community came
out and was
absolutely amazing and i um on
i want to say it was last friday i
tweeted um
like a very simple tweet like a very
like easy tweet to make which was i
donated thirty dollars
to the to the to black lives matter um
and
it was it was my homie yusuf who works
at ubisoft um
yusuf you know during all of the the
the donations that were going on uh
toward the the
uh minnesota bail fund um you know he
pointed out that yeah it's awesome that
people
are giving to this um but this is a this
is an ongoing fight and you should look
into different organizations and
different
international organizations like black
lives matter that are do that are
a part of the fight um and are doing
this on an international level and so
that was the thing that inspired me to
give to black lives matter and i just i
just
simply retweeted his tweet and gave
thirty dollars and that was it
and from there over the weekend
throughout the week so many people
rose up to the occasion and matched it
and like replied to them they're like
hey i'm also giving money and quote
tweet that
and said hey i'm also giving money to
the point where i lost count right like
you know over like pro at this point
actually hundreds of interactions of
people donating
uh to black lives matter within our
community the kind of funny community
and within the
the gaming community in general and
that's been one of the most like
coolest things i've seen come out of
gaming communities right like i think
so so often we look at comments we look
at
online we look at um gaming communities
and we're like
yeah people can be terrible a lot of the
time right like especially talking about
this today
as far as like call of duty and the
things that you get while you're while
you're talking
uh in in voice chat right like people
like to throw slurs people like to be
terrible a lot of the time
but this last weekend was one of those
weekends where i was like
man it i feel good about where i'm at i
feel good
being able to uh to be a part of the
kind of funny community and a part of
the gaming community
if people are willing to rise up and
actually give and actually have their
voice heard and actually
uh rise the occasion and so in that
sense like
it's it's been amazing to see i hope it
continues i hope people continue to feel
empowered
uh to fight against what's wrong and to
fight for justice
um and yeah it's been really cool
yeah actually it seems like i you know
we launched
a charity as well and just like seeing
them in max community turn up for this
like oh it just felt like there's this
pelt up
pent-up feeling of just like we want to
help how can we help
sir i'm curious i haven't talked to you
yet um but being in minneapolis
do you have insight that you can share
with the world just about being
it's weird to call it the epicenter
because it's been a problem that's
around for so long
in so many different places but what do
you think just like from the minneapolis
perspective
uh yeah it's been sort of interesting
because i've been it's this weird mix of
why i want to stay indoors because you
know there's a whole other thing going
on besides oh yeah
yeah uh the process and stuff but it's
been this weird mix of like do i go
outside or not to you know to do what i
can and
just here it feels like it's not it
doesn't feel like in a cute thing that's
just like oh this event happened it is
feel like something
is ongoing still you know like i hear
helicopters like every night which is
very strange to hear
um and just seeing a lot of like people
walking around more so than i think i've
heard around it feels like this is
this is going to be more than like a
moment it feels like and i'm hoping
that's you know
that we can affect positive change
through this that people that this is
like a breaking point in a way that
other kind of similar movements haven't
been
yeah and it seems like we're nearing
there with more people severing ties you
know with the police overall
um jake the game ranks community do you
have any insight into just how they've
been
handling this uh so just generally
on social uh i have a tendency to put
things out and go okay here we go
uh but it seems like something where
there's
everybody has a general consensus about
like
the the right and wrong with it it's the
people get lost and arguing in the
nuances which are important nuances but
it seems like overall everybody is
you know at least positive for the
bottom line and uh
haven't had a lot of trolls or anything
the biggest thing i'm struggling with is
uh
figuring out what to say on our friday
show we have like a weekly
news roundup that i host and i can't
not say anything so i'm still trying to
figure out
the right way to say things because i'm
like angry but i i i feel like
my other mission is like i like to
engage and convert so
it's just trying to figure out how to
say things not just to like
not pissing off that's not that's not
the case it's
how to kind of bring more people in and
help them
listen yeah make the most of the
platform overall
yeah yeah um does anybody have any
advice for if people
um can't afford to donate uh to either
the causes at the bottom of just
how to help in the situation
yell at your parents oh i don't i don't
have links i've seen a lot of things
that
are generating ad revenue that is going
to be used for charity charitable
purposes
and i saw a lot of people in our chat uh
posting those links but again i just
these were links i'm seeing flyby so
yeah i haven't i haven't double checked
a lot of that stuff but i know that
there are avenues
i imagine that's yeah that's something
i'd definitely plan with a quick search
i'm definitely big into like signal
boosting
and like retweeting and like letting
people letting if you don't have the
funds that's okay
you know uh let somebody who has the
funds uh let them know what's going on
and let them know how they can help
um and also educate yourself right like
go in like you know
listen sit down like hear read
understand like figure out ways in which
you can
uh uh learn how how to better this
country right and how to better like the
experience for
for for everyone living here right like
uh
everybody's been talking about the ben
and jerry's statement but i really like
that statement
and i like to point to that statement as
an example of like hey
this is ben and jerry's on their website
right for people who might not be aware
like
like they they put out a statement that
is uh a long statement detailing
kind of exactly what the issues are
right like you know
this this country was founded on on
certain ideals that
today don't age well right like this
country
since since its inception right like has
been
has been built on racism and uh
like since since the founding of this
country
there have been systems in place right
whether political systems
whether it's social systems whether it's
their corporate systems
that have been in place that reflected
those times and those systems are still
in place
um i highly recommend people go to that
ben and jerry statement and read through
it because that ben and jerry statement
kind of lays out
exactly like a step by step of where we
can go from here um i know like even
even uh former president barack obama
right had like a good twitter thread
that that laid out like hey there's a pr
these are practical things that we can
do um and at the very least right like
you know you may not have the funds but
you can vote uh and not just vote for
the president but vote at your your
local um
and state levels too because that's
actually what's going to make a
difference when it comes to things like
policing
um and so those those are the things i
say right educate yourself
vote um share the word
yeah alessandro uh do you have some
donations here to wrap it up
uh sure yeah we have um uh
dylan blank with a 25 dollars for game
squad stands with black lives matter and
we have uh
uh cbs his own cbs interactive zone uh
uh giuliana russell who um
you know has been a great friend or for
the last year
um and uh she's been great helping us
out at gamespot so
and uh and for uh direct relief we have
uh ten bucks once again from uh kristen
jaggi
uh with a message saying has anyone seen
kyle bossman recently i
i let him borrow my snes and he's never
gave it back to me i really want to play
some games these days
well hey on that note that seems like
the perfect way to close this out
um thank you so much for everybody that
uh donated we really
appreciate it any other messages anybody
else wants to convey get off their chest
about
the saga we're going through i want to
rebuild sure
let's do it oh i definitely want to take
jake down it's a feeling i've had for a
long time
let's do it yeah ben thanks for putting
this together and thanks everybody for
showing up there's lots of scheduling
moving around this week and everybody
just seemed really enthusiastic about
being here today and being involved in
this the trivia part was aside you know
that was terrifying
absolutely and thanks for uh for you
know to gamespot for opening the whole
thing up sorry alexander
say something uh uh just uh
just to follow up with a blessing said
uh it all begins with just
be having the willingness to listen to
people just to open yourselves up and
just letting you know
uh having that desire to just uh you
know listen to like a different
uh sort of perspective on things because
that's really what it comes down to and
that's always
i can guarantee you that it's much
better to have the conversation with
a person of color or black writer or you
know a friend
you know from a different community
before you make a decision versus
the conversation that comes after making
a really dumb decision so
i'm sure you which we've seen many times
over like you know the last few days
where
um you know different companies are
trying to
come up with ways to sort of like you
know make things right but maybe it
doesn't
necessarily come out the right way so um
but again it always comes down to just
having that willingness and just having
that desire to you know listen to the
wealth
of black writers uh black content
creators you know and other
um specifically you know women of color
as well as well and
you know just uh yeah that's that's kind
of just what i want to say so
yeah absolutely uh well hey um this
whole charity drive doesn't end here
right alessandro like we have how many
more days of streams from gamespot
uh we have uh about six more weeks left
of streaming uh
for uh uh for play for all we've a lot
coming up
um and uh of course we got some stuff
happening tomorrow as well
um we uh we can expect to see uh
i believe uh jesus here's toast uh doing
a bloodborne speed run
right so that should be uh exciting so
awesome super cool so please look
forward to that
and again thank you for donating we
appreciate uh every little bit
it all adds up thanks so much everybody
we'll see you next time
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]